[Musique]
moi,
donc pour mon
programme de troisième cycle, je dois au
gouvernement un peu moins de 12 000 livres
et cela n'a pas encore eu d'intérêt ajouté,
heureusement parce que cela
vient de commencer cette euh
cette année universitaire
de ma vie de premier cycle,
je dois environ 63 000  livres
donc en moyenne on ne parle ici
que des personnes qui ont bénéficié d'
une formation universitaire
mais il est vrai que les diplômés les plus riches
seront un peu mieux lotis à l'avenir
et certains diplômés plus pauvres
seront un peu moins bien lotis  parce qu'ils
rembourseront plus de leurs prêts
et certaines personnes pensent que c'est injuste,
donc il
y a beaucoup de politique brute ici, je
pense que les dernières décisions reflètent le
fait que le gouvernement, euh,
ne recherche pas particulièrement les votes des
jeunes
et également du parti travailliste  a
promis d'abolir les frais de scolarité
et court après les votes des jeunes
[Musique]
vous